hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir die xxl
schokotorte aus dem 10
mathilde und heute meine damen und
herren ist ein ganz besonderer tag für
mich für euch und für die ganze
menschheit denn heute ist der offizielle
start eines kochbuchs wie schmeckt
überall erhältlich wo es bücher gibt
unser feier des tages ist so eine fette
schokotorte doch das aller allerbeste
und ich muss dazu sagen es ist mein
absoluter traum einmal da so rein zu
greifen wie benno ich glaube ich wäre es
heute nicht machen weil das wäre dann
schon schade um die torte
aber wer den film nicht kennt der muss
ihn sich wirklich mal anschauen für mich
ist das ein absoluter klassiker ich habe
ihn als kind schon soviel mal gesehen
als erwachsener dann auch immer mal
wieder besonders ich glaube zur
weihnachtszeit kommt der falls ich mich
jetzt nicht irre es geht um ein kleines
mädchen mit ganz besonderen kräften die
in einer ein bisschen schrägen familie
aufwächst und das ist ein schöner film
ich möchte nicht zu viel wegnehmen falls
ihr noch nicht gesehen habt und die ihn
gesehen haben haben haben die wissen ja
worum es geht und ganz zufälligerweise
habe ich das fahrrad gibt ein kochbuch
ich habe darüber den soundtrack von dem
film matilda ganz lange als mein handy
tun
und jedes mal wenn mich jemand angerufen
hat dieser soundtrack kommt übrigens
auch wenn sie anfangen mit ihren kräften
ich habe ganz überlegen wie könnte ich
diese zauberkräfte ins video bringen
also auch ganz magische weise eine
mutter schweben zu lassen
der wodka oder wie macht sie das
aber damit leider das team fehlt mir den
ich irgendwelche schnüre ziehen kann
oder mir irgendwelche sachen sor
eingeschwebt werden habe ich eine ganz
andere methode gefunden zu zaubern
denn passend zum start des kochbuchs
habe ich überlegt mir eine website zu
erstellen und ich sehe euch ganz ehrlich
mit wakes funktioniert das fast wie
zauberei ich sollte eigentlich
werbeslogans schreie vielleicht hat er
auch schon mal vor einem youtube-video
eine fixe werbung gesehen babes
schneller ist mix werbeslogan maschine
ihr könnt euch mit wx eure eigene
website erstellen und das super einfach
kleine geschichten dieser seite ich
hatte mal eine ausbildung als
mediengestalterin angefangen und dort
musste ich lernen mit html webseiten zu
erstellen ich habe es damals einfach
nicht hinbekommen diese website zu
erstellen
es war so kompliziert man musste ja
wirklich noch die ganzen codes eingeben
zahlen und wie nennt man das befehle und
es war endlich jeder der schonmal html
vielleicht benutzt hat und gut darin ist
sorry aber für mich war das so schwer
und deswegen wertschätze ich anbieter
wie mix einfach viel mehr weil ich weiß
wie kompliziert es eigentlich ist und
wie unglaublich einfach es mit meinem
kühlschrank macht gerade eis
lass dir zeit
das werde ich man hat dort wirklich
hunderte verschiedene möglichkeiten wie
man seine website gestalten kann und lay
aus an dem man sich orientieren kann auf
meiner website zum beispiel habe ich die
hintergrundfarbe dem cover vom buch
angepasst mehr als sich in der
ausbildung geschafft habe aber natürlich
kann man dort auch bilder einfügen die
social media accounts verlinken und was
ich mir gut finde meine youtube videos
auf die website packen und dass man sie
dort auch schauen kann und das habe ich
auch gemacht also da hat man dann quasi
das buch dann einen link wo man das buch
kaufen kann und dann noch die videos die
zu dem buch erscheinen und wenn man sich
jetzt für das buch interessiert und auf
die website geht dann kann man gleich
sehen
diese videos gab es schon zu dem buch
was hat sie denn da gemacht oder wenn
man zum beispiel hilfe braucht bei einem
rezept oder irgendwie schauen und möchte
wie ich das gemacht habe dann kann man
zum beispiel auch die videos anklicken
unten kann man dann auch zum beispiel
noch die aufmacher seiten sehen da kann
man sehen welche kategorien da drin sind
und ich find's einfach mega cool es ist
wirklich so leicht und intuitiv und das
kann wirklich jeder vielleicht habt ihr
schon mal darüber nachgedacht euch eure
eigene website zu erstellen und dafür
habe ich sogar einen rabattcode mal war
mit zehn und damit bekommt ihr zehn
prozent rabatt auf eure eigene website
bist du bereit für deine eigene
webseiten auf zuwachs denn schneller ist
nix also falls sich das mal genauer
anschauen wollt unten findet ihr
natürlich den link dazu und jetzt machen
wir uns an die torte ich kann euch jetzt
schon verraten in die torte kommt sehr
sehr viel schokolade hey es ist eine xxl
schokotorte was habt ihr erwartet ich
merke aber gerade das ist doch noch ein
bisschen winter ist und mir echt kalt
ist ich hole mir ganz kurze jacke
waisenkind aus so einem hollywood ich
hab keine
das ist auf jeden fall zu schildern so
das rezept oder schokotorte ist ein
bisschen tricky weil man es auch zwei
tage aufteilen sollte glaubt mir das
erspart euch stress und ein paar zutaten
brauchen ihre zeit wir waren wir geben
erst mal mit der füllung und der creme
der torte für die füllung brauchen wir
super fuß wie vollmilch schokolade oder
sahne und butter und für die creme
drumherum zartbitterschokolade und sahen
wie geil ist meine küche bitte endlich
kann ich es ausnutzen dass ich eine
herdplatte vorne haben und nun müssen
wir die sahne aufkochen sahne in einen
topf geben
jetzt kochen wir sie auch und während
sie auf kocht schokolade schon gelogen
ich fühle mich gerade echt wie bei
seiner kochshow jetzt nehmen die
schokolade dairy schokolade schwer
[Musik]
übrigens wurde bei meinem letzten trip
stream ein fehler im kochbuch entdeckt
vielleicht habt ihr ja auch schon
entdeckt durch zauberei wurde diese
scolaris geschnitten
ich weiß gerade nicht was ich
aufgenommen haben falls ich gerade zu
blöd war um zu filmen die ich die sahne
vom topf nehme die schokolade da rein
mache und dann es führe und hier rein
kippe seht ihr das jetzt bei der creme
gut gemachte nest und die creme fängt
genau gleich an
wir brauchen sahne
die müssen wir ersetzen und jetzt
brauchen wir noch mehr schokolade
diesmal dritter kommt es mir nur so vor
da sehe ich in diesem kleid ein bisschen
schwanger und ich habe irgendwie das
gefühl dass dieses kleid dafür gemacht
ist um schwanger zu sein als ob ich lust
schwanger zu sein
ein bisschen material zauberei kann ich
euch auch zeigen
hallo mein name ist matilda und ich
hätte jetzt gern die sahne aufgekocht
noch sie kocht jetzt ja kochen sie kocht
jetzt gastiert ich dich so einmal runter
reb und 30.000 kilo schokolade reine
schokolade rey und jetzt schön früheren
mainzer bitterschokolade wird es ein
bisschen länger dauern bis sie sich
aufgelöst hat
ich habe gerade wenn es für bewegung
machen das sieht einfach aus wie der
krasseste schokopudding r schaut euch
das an es ist so schokoladig das sind
unsere beiden schokoladencreme es einmal
für die füllung und für außen und für
die führungen müssen wir aber noch
weitermachen die bleibt jetzt so aber
beide müssen uns erst mal stehen bleiben
und abkühlen eigentlich steht jetzt in
meinem kopf hoch dass man den kuchenteig
am tag zwei machen soll da ich aber
morgen extrem wenig zeit habe und heute
dafür umso mehr mache ich denn schon
heute
wir packen ihn dann einfach ein und
haben ihn am morgen bereit können wir
auch machen wenn ihr wollt das macht man
sich so wie man smart wir sind ein
freies land also seid artikel 13 nicht
mehr ganz so frei aber du machst mich
fertig und wer hätt's gedacht dafür
müssen wir wieder in einem topf ganz
viel butter schmelzen und zu der
geschmolzene butter geben wir jetzt
unsere zart butter schokolade
[Musik]
und wenn sich dann die schokolade so
richtig schön aufgelöst hat kommt dann
auch so ein richtig schöner becher sahne
sein
das schmeckt und ist schwer und dann
nochmal verrühren und wenn ihr das jetzt
trinkt dann braucht sie für eine woche
lang nicht mehr essen
und nun brauchen wir ganz schön viele
eier richtig viele eier und mit richtig
viele eier meine ich richtig viele die
wissen wir jetzt rühren mit unserer
zauberkraft bewegen sich von selbst
tötete würde weiße gold kommt dazu und
wird eingerührt ein bisschen vanille
aroma von zwei prisen salz rein macht
was und jetzt kommt und wird
schokocreme zu den sünden leute das ist
einfach sinne das baby hat ganz schön
gewicht das ist eine große schüssel und
hier ist das monster was wir schaffen
haben wir haben jetzt eine mischung aus
mehl backpulver und kakaopulver es war
ja noch nicht genug schokolade und die
hauen wir jetzt mal rein
am besten ist wenn man die trockenen
zutaten nach und nach rain gibt und
immer wieder rührt dann vermeidet man
klumpen ich habe euch einen xxl kuchen
versprochen ihr bekommt einen xxl ach so
eine zutat habe ich nicht übernommen in
der szene wird nämlich gesagt dass sie
ihr blut und ihr schweiß in diesen
kuchen rein getan hat das haben wir
einfach mal über höher den rufen müssen
wir auch 150 grad vorheizen und in der
zeit hätten wir uns so richtig zwei
springform 1 und in eine springform
packte zwei drittel in die andere ein
drittel rein ja auch beim backen
brauchen manchmal macht und wenn ihr zum
beispiel nur eine springform habt dann
könnt ihr das auf drei aufteilen oder
ihr macht erstmals zwei drittel zieht es
raus und macht auch noch mal dass ein
drittel oder ihr habt drei springen
formen und dann könnt ihr das
gleichmäßig verteilen aber ich finde mit
zwei dritteln ein drittel passen
am besten und ich finde dass es bei der
matildas rotor jetzt nicht so wichtig
ist ob die böden alle gleich groß ziehen
weil das ist ja so eine schokoladige
matscht orte wo man einfach nur so rein
langen möchte und nicht so wisst was ich
meine
ja und ich werde jetzt den teig backen
abkühlen lassen schlafengehen und wir
sehen uns morgen wieder also jetzt so
leute tag 2 und heute machen wir die
torte fertig es geht jetzt weiter mit
der füllung ich war so blüm einem
kochbuch steht dass man die creme
einfach nur stehen lassen soll also an
einem kühlen ort stellen und einfach
zugedeckt stehen lassen
ich habe es einen kühlschrank gepackt
und dann mach ich heute morgen auf macht
die küche raus und denken wir so scheiße
ja was ist beide cremes total fest ich
habe die außen creme jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen aufgewärmt und gehört damit sie
wieder weicher wird aber ich habe mir
gedacht wie blöd kann ich sein in meinem
kopf buch steht es doch wie es gemacht
wird ich vertraue mir selber nicht heute
sehe ich aber nicht ich schwanger aus
sondern wie so eine richtige gute
hausfrau und mein mann kommt gleich von
der arbeit nach hause ich mag ihn noch
schnell einen schokokuchen denn das ist
eine lieblingsseite nicht backen für
mich damit ich ihn traurig im bett
alleine für die füllung müssen wir jetzt
die butter auf schloss und meine kids
schnell das ganz von alleine
schaut mal so hell wird sie also wie
kann die wird richtig richtig jetzt
ruhig ein bisschen schwächer und geben
dabei nach und nach diese mega
geilenkirchen coco das finde das ist
unsere fluffige helle schokocreme
okay wir müssen auf den zwei bühnen
müssen wir jetzt drei teile machen also
einfach hier so schön den kopf weg oh
mein gott und stresst euch nicht ob der
gerade ist oder nicht wenn der lenker
ist wird das kein interessiert mein
ganzes schaut euch diese schönheit an
und wieder riecht nach
das kommt jetzt darauf als erster boden
jetzt will ich aus wie nach hausfrau in
ihrer eigenen kochshow hallo leute und
jetzt müssen wir die füllung rein machen
denn mit einem spritzbeutel wird es
schön gleichmäßig jetzt kommt echter
beste bad saarow for kids den dgb nur
eins ein bisschen an drückend ist ja
gerade ist ungebrochen ist und wo ist
noch weit
[Musik]
seine denke mein gott das ist mal
methode und jetzt kommt die cremes die
creme de la creme wie gesagt stellt wie
nicht in den kühlschrank dann suche ich
jetzt mal zu verschmieren
das gute ist bei dieser torte dass die
cremig so perfekt drauf liegen muss
sondern eher so grob und ich drücke ich
unser kopf menge geben drauf das ist die
leute die schokotorte aus dem ziel
mathea und sie ist so schwer das ist so
ein riesenteil get what i said absolut
get what i said und für den allerletzten
menschen denn dieser mond lebt mein buch
ist jetzt draußen ihr könnt euch das
unten mit dem link bestellen oder ihr
geht in die buchhandlung so wie ihr es
am liebsten mögen und jetzt steht es
euch und jetzt schneiden wir die torte
an es geht durch wie butter
[Musik]
muss sie noch irgendwas dazu sagen und
jetzt stellen wir es natürlich wieder
der allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
die xxl schokotorte aus dem film
mathildes gibt es die
[Musik]
die ist so schokoladig um mein gott die
ist so lecker und packt die cremes nicht
in den kühlschrank
reminder so dickes ding
mein gott kann ich gar nicht beschreiben
wie schokolade schmeckt und danach
sollte man auf jeden fall ins
fitnessstudio ich hoffe natürlich hat
die folge gefallen und wenn ja dann
zeigt es mir mit einem daumen nach oben
das würde mich sehr freuen und abonniert
den kanal falls jetzt noch nicht getan
habt hier kommen nämlich teile koch und
back videos und anderes zeug und denkt
daran falls ihr euch eine eigene website
erstellen wollte ganz einfach und
schnell dann schaut man bei vix vorbei
mit dem x wanne 10 code kriegt ihr auch
zehn prozent rabatt auf die website und
die links sind und in der beschreibung
genau so wie der link zu meinem kochbuch
ich sag jetzt tschüss bis zum nächsten
mal mich hat sehr gefreut und bis dann
ich gehe jetzt mit meinem kochbuch
schlafen also ich lege mich einfach nur
mit dem kochbuch ins bett nicht das was
ihr gedacht habt